and finally the last type of all of this
before starting to learn before breaking
out your notebook breaking out your
computer and starting your week one or
your week six or your week eight is
asking chat GPT this simple question
ready hello everybody my name is Naya
and I'm the black female engineer I
provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers and today we're going
to be talking about chat GPT really the
thing everybody and their model has been
talking about but today we're really
going to talk about
how we can use chat gbt to learn to code
in pretty lightning speed so let's get
into it
[Music]
so quick story time in 2020 I went to a
coding boot camp for four months it was
a 16 week coding boot camp and it cost
an arm and a leg literally over fifteen
thousand dollars now I do not know and I
kind of already don't think I would have
done that or at least been so quick to
do that if Chad gbt had been a thing
then as it is now the reason for this is
because I would have simply gone to
chat.openai.com and asked hey I want to
learn to code in four to six months I
have this amount of time I can devote to
learning to code what should my study
plan be what should my lesson plan be
what should I devote each day to
learning and then it would have said
well well first do this then do this
then do this and boom I don't need to
spend fifteen thousand dollars to go to
a coding boot camp because I have an
instructor and a guide right here so it
is now it is not then so really the best
thing I can do now is simply show you
all how I would have gone about that
process and how you can save all that
money save all that headache and become
a software engineer in four to six
months I'll use the time frame of four
months for this video because that's
what my boot camp was but you can alter
this to be whatever amount of time you
want so first things first the way you
would go about using chatgpt to learn to
code in four months and eventually get a
job is first we need to figure out how
we are going about studying how many
hours we are devoting per week towards
this and how to break out those hours
per day per week Etc if you've been
wanting to learn to code one of the
questions you may be asking is shoot I
am a full-time worker I don't have the
time where do I even put the time to
learn to code and just the confusion and
worry of that all the angst of that all
stopping you from learn to code in
general so let's get rid of that right
now and ask Chad gbt how we should
schedule our days in order to get our
hours in so I only get my laptop right
here
and straight up right now ask
how many hours per week should be put in
for this goal and boom right there we
see that it says 20 to 30 hours per week
should be devoted to learning to code if
your timeline is for months for getting
everything you need to know to get a
junior software engineer doing your full
stack developer type role so now we know
we need 20 to 30 hours allocated towards
coding per week where do we put this
time let me ask chat GPT I'm gonna put
in how many hours I work full time or
part-time in really any blockers to my
time I may have me personally I'm a 24
year old I don't have dependents I don't
have really anything other than a
full-time job stopping me from going
towards this goal so I'm going to put
that in and see what it says and real
quick another thing that's important to
me is having time to rest I feel like I
would just experience so much brain
frying if I just wet ham just seven days
a week no rest days no time off and so
I'm going to actually tell Taj Deputy to
let Sundays be a rest day and see what
it says so very clearly here it says to
devote two hours in the morning before
work three hours in the afternoon during
lunch and two hours in the evening after
work towards learning to code this right
here gives us what four and a half hours
per day and on top of that learn to code
on Saturdays for four to six hours I
love that Saturday isn't a full work day
because it lets me do what I said before
still enjoy my weekend still enjoy the
opportunity to rest socialize X Y and Z
that allows us 26 and a half to 28 and a
half hours of coding of learning to code
per week which is just under that 30
hour threshold it had put as our Max
which I think is pretty damn good okay
perfect we know how many hours per week
to devote to this we know how to
structure our week and our days to learn
to code so now let's ask chai gbt what
our week by week lesson plan should look
like I'm going to Simply ask what should
I spend each week learning please
provide a 16 week breakdown and here it
is just pitting it all out for us so
it's one to two three to four five to
six all the way and so on until week 16.
so that's great we have an outline of
what we should focus on each week what
lessons what types of Concepts we should
focus our energies on week by week
however like I just said it's really
just an outline and outlines are great
it helps us see Direction but when I
don't know what I don't know I'm gonna
need more than just an outline so I now
week by week I'm going to ask for a
detailed breakdown of what I should be
learning let's start out with that very
first output weeks one and two 2. Chachi
BT said to focus on HTML and CSS Basics
along with finishing off the week with
some JavaScript sounds great
um what Basics what Basics are we
talking about so let me ask Chad GPT
this specific question what HTML and CSS
Concepts should I learn during weeks one
and two and with that question it spits
out all of the detailed lessons I should
focus on for those weeks structure and
syntax elements and tags attributes
semantic HTML HTML forms and that's just
the HTML now for CSS it says selectors
box models styling properties layout and
positioning so now I can reasonably feel
like I have the true proper direction
for week one of my learning and then to
really make sure we have everything
solidified we need some type of way to
test what we've learned test if what we
have learned is enough to move forward
and so again let's ask chat to be T how
we can test that after learning HTML and
CSS for one week what is a good way to
test my aptitude and here lists out a
couple of different things you can do
the two I would love for you all to
focus on are creating a basic site and
replicating a basic site those are two
very good ways of testing your skills
and also refining your skills while uh
while learning at the same time now this
is great right we know what we should
learn when we should learn it and all
that but okay how are we going to learn
it we need some resources so I'm going
to ask hey what free resources do you
recommend for me learning HTML and CSS
it spits out some recommendations some
you have heard me talk about if you are
not using my channel for example free
code Camp I love that's how I started
learning specifically HTML CSS and some
I haven't spoken about too much but
they're definitely worth your time
definitely go through the list and see
which resources you like the most which
ones work best for your learning style
and which ones don't and finally the
last type of all of this before starting
to learn and before breaking out your
notebook picking out your computer and
starting your week one or your week six
or your week eight is asking chat GPT
this simple question ready
if you were trying to teach me HTML for
the very first time what would you say
now of course HTML can and should be
replaced with whatever you'll be
learning that week but the reason this
is so important is because it will
provide you the proper uh basic
understanding for why what you're
learning is important why you're
learning what you're learning and what
to expect in your lessons when we're in
week two and we're learning JavaScript I
would ask the same question If you're
trying to teach me JavaScript for the
very first time what would you say to me
that way I understand the importance of
this concept of this language and use
that to get me through my days and my
weeks follow this formula for each week
each concept you are supposed to be
learning one ask what specific Concepts
you should be learning for that week you
are in remember with ht1 CSS it gave us
the very clear
um items that we should be checking off
the list while we're learning and that's
how we know how far deep we're in and we
can use that to track our progress
number two ask how you can test your
knowledge for what you've been learning
for the week one we saw that by
replicating a site or building a basic
site that is a great way of testing our
HTML and CSS knowledge three ask what
resources are best feel free to also
include any other uh things that would
be important to you in a resource is it
free is it low cost does it provide
videos is it mostly reading based feel
free to include any parameters you'd
want chat GPT to include in this answer
then finally ask if you were trying to
teach me X for the very first time
trying to teach me HTML CSS JavaScript
react sequel for the very first time
what would you say to me another way you
can phrase this question is explain this
concept so that a six-year-old could
understand explain so and so so that
somebody with no previous experience can
understand and then boom you are very
well on your way towards a career in
software development all thanks to chat
GPT so there you go everybody I hope
this was helpful please let me know what
your thoughts are what things are y'all
trying to learn even if it's not coding
related if it is if if catch EBT has
already helped you in some way please
put it down in the comments because I
would love to know I'd love to get the
new ideas of what things I can learn in
the future so thank you so much y'all
and I hope you have a great rest of your
day bye all
oh my God
this what is this yeah
be attacked
three two
yeah